olive aurait aurélien véron conseiller
municipal et l'air à paris bonsoir à
vous merci d'être en ligne avec nous sur
rt france votre bilan le bilan que vous
faites du grand retour des gilets jaunes
dans les rues de paris aujourd'hui
d'abord je suis inquiet par cette
banalisation de la violence qui se
traduit par des commentaires un peu de
hauteur du style finalement ça s'est
bien passé j'ai tout de même vu jean
marie bigard se faire évacuer écrit très
par des gardes du corps menacé d'un
lynchage physique place de la bourse
et j'étais à côté donc j'ai vu la petite
foule très agitée nous avons vu des
voitures brûlées une voiture détruite
nous avons vu un parisien se prendre une
grande mandales dans la figure est tombé
à la renverse agressé par un black bloc
donc ces voitures brûlées ces barricades
en feu et séjours agressés tous les
parisiens que avec qui j'échange mme
expriment le même sentiment
il y a un très grand ras-le-bol des
parisiens de voir leur ville se
transformer en champ de bataille
quand c'est pas les finales de foot ce
bayern psg très des gilets jaunes quand
c'est pas les gilet jaune c'était le 1er
mai en 2018 et chaque fois les mêmes des
centaines ou milliers de casseurs de
pilleurs de black blocks d'extrême
gauche viennent se servir de paris comme
un dépotoir
alors je sais bien que la mairie de
paris transforme lentement paris en rade
avec ces plots jaunes ces barrières en
béton
mais ces incidents répétés qu'ils sont
en train de se remettre en place et
qu'on va voir tous les samedis à l'hoggy
crise économique qu'on n'a pas connue
depuis la guerre ça m'inquiète
énormément et je peux vous dire que les
parisiens sont extrêmement effrayée et
voient leur activité économique l'ordi
familiale les on a vu des immeubles
brûlé je vous rappelle en 2020 environ
2019 donc c'est pas anodin c'est en
train de se passer et quand j'entends
les revendications qui sont très
confuses part qu'elles ont été récupérés
depuis l'origine on est parti d'une sur
fiscalité à il faut taxer les riches
je vous rappelle que 57 % du pib et
dépensé par l'état et donc le l'état
c'est plus de la moitié de la croissance
économique delà de la création de valeur
en volant pays je veux dire que l'état
verse un tiers de la richesse nationale
on aide sociale et en prestations
sociales donc on est un pays qui est
extrêmement généreux en aide sociale que
vole saison ces gens veulent la
révolution ils veulent brûler paris
on n'est rien prévient aurélien véron va
parler des revendications des gilet
jaune juste sur le déroulé de cette
journée c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
tensions des heurts entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants dans le
xviie arrondissement
mais on voit que la sur la fin de
journée vous êtes peut-être vous êtes
d'accord avec moi ça fait quand même
plutôt bien terminée la dispersion elle
se fait dans des conditions relativement
calme là dessus on a connu dès samedi
pire on reconnaissait camp j'espère
d'ailleurs que ce soir la nuit tombée on
va par voir partir les casseurs qui sont
embusqués en attendant qu'ils passent
nuit donc pour l'instant c'est calme
c'est une bonne chose
nous avons eu un lot d'agression et de
vandalisme bombe a effectivement fait
banal il ya eu que deux ou trois
voitures brûlées quelques barricades
quelques parisiens qui ont été tabassés
mais c'est pas grave c'est pas ça finit
bien
et bien moi je dis ça se finit pas bien
c'est quand même une mauvaise journée
c'est un point noir dans la vie de paris
et paris n'a pas besoin de ça
aujourd'hui
donc ces revendications il avait
beaucoup de manifestations en france et
j'ai entendu avant moi une intervenante
exprimé dire depuis un an ton métier son
hobby à plein-temps cdp des manifs
bon ben d'accord alors monté des manifs
en france c'est devenu un métier
effectivement que les manifs la saison
juste sonnés les revendications vous
parlais tout à l'heure des aides
sociales
c'est gilet jaune pour une grande partie
justement à la fin du mois ils
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
ils sont très nombreux à le dire ils
l'ont dit durant des 5 10 consécutifs ya
eu c'est vrai ce confinement
cette trêve estivale aujourd'hui quand
on a longtemps dans l'oreille on sent
bien que la situation à la pas vraiment
changé pour beaucoup d'entre eux il ya
des gens qui n'arrivent pas à joindre
les deux bouts à la fin du mois malgré
les aides sociales que vous évoquez
quand l'état charolles plus de la moitié
de la richesse nationale
évidemment qu'il reste plus grand chose
pour les gens et quand on a un chômage
il ya une préférence pour le chômage
parce que le modèle social conseil je
vous rappel c'est la préférence pour le
chômage on est le pays de l'union
européenne qui est un taux de chômage
parmi les plus élevés
tous nos voisins ont un taux de chômage
qui est la moitié d'une autre donc on a
un modèle économique fondé sur le
chômage de masse sur la précarité et sur
un état obèse
évidemment que les plus forts les plus
fragiles il touche des miettes et ses
miettes sont petites mais à force de
vouloir cogner sur les parisiens
systématiquement ou sur les grandes
villes parce qu'on a eu
on a eu des grandes villes avant paris
en 2019 qui ont été aussi saccagé
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va rétablir une
justice sociale l'altiste sociale c'est
d'abord de l'emploi et l'emploi qu'il
est qu'ils fabriquent les pme les deux
pays
les entreprises j'aimerais bien voir les
gilet jaune défendre le soulagement
bureaucratique le soulagement fiscal le
soulagement administratif
d'où ces pme françaises qui sont en
train de mourir parce que la crise
économique est en train de démarrer par
qu'elle démarre en ce moment elle est en
train de tuer les pme et c'est les pme
qui vont assurer l'emploi et le pouvoir
d'achat
je moi je demande au gilet jaune tournez
vous vers les entrepreneurs les petits
entrepreneurs qui gagne pas très bien
dormi et est délaissé eux qui vont créer
l'emploi qui vont créer la richesse de
demain voilà non merci
aurélien véron je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller l'air à paris merci